so Beth my wife anytime we listen to a
song and she says I love this song my
next thought is I have to ruin that
so she loves this song The Weight by the
band
and so uh I thought I'd ruin it for you
here you go babe
two three four
when I was a teenager I masturbated
every day
one faithful morning I looked the wrong
way
I looked down too early
way way too early
I shot the load right on me
[Applause]
[Music]
go girlfriend Sally
went down on me
that it never happened I felt happy and
so free she said hey please warn me
before you go please warn me
you better warn me
[Applause]
hey
she spit the load back on me
[Music]
yo Josh yeah you know this has kind of
inspired me you mind if I take a verse
yeah go ahead dude
[Applause]
I met a guy named Danny back in my
college days
didn't know when I met him that I would
go both ways I had sex with Danny
having sex with Danny
had sex with Daddy yeah yeah yeah and
Danny had sex with me
[Music]
[Applause]
three true stories
ah it's just just around you
know what I mean I like to smoke weed
bring it
I like to smoke weed bring it
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]